I am glad to be here at Strange Loop my
name is Jamie Jennings I recently
finished a short 19-year career at IBM
in the time in the time between
submitting this talk a few months ago
and now I have moved from IBM to NC
State where I am now once again a
professor of computer science and rosie
has moved from github to get lab we are
both happy in our new digs so I'm going
to tell you a story about a
domain-specific language and I hope that
some people will take away a meta-level
message which is sometimes creating a
domain-specific language is a really
good way to solve a class of problems
and so this story began while I was at
IBM and my team had to write lots of
regular expressions and we found a
number of things that we did not
anticipate about what happens when you
have a large collection of regular
expressions used by a large collection
of people writing in different
programming languages Python Perl
Scala Java etc etc even even a little
bit of C and C++ and also when the data
size is increased we found interesting
performance anomalies that kind of
panicked us briefly but we went on and I
designed rosy pattern language as a way
of solving some of the issues that we
had with regular expressions so by the
way I'm I'm used to teaching and so I
usually walk around and like actually
physically point at the screen which I
can't do here without risk of falling
off the stage so so yeah I could walk
around behind the screen but that looks
weird okay so I may walk around a little
bit but I know for the camera I should
try to keep still sorry this was the
situation that at IBM when I was working
on Rosie initially we had it within IBM
cloud a set of DevOps tools and they
include
several hundred tool integrations a few
of the popular ones are shown at the
bottom and they include source code
repositories and issue tracking systems
and requirements management systems and
unit tests and build systems and
deployment systems and what we were
trying to do in my group is take all of
the digital exhaust if you've heard that
term all of the metadata and logging
data that is spewed off by these systems
as they run and see if we could come up
with useful insights to give back to the
development teams about their projects
so we were trying to measure things like
how agile is your project
how did changes in your projects
management affect your ability to
respond to issues quickly how much
effort are you spending on issues versus
bugs and in fact we could even do a
reasonably good prediction of which
files which changes to which files are
more likely to have bugs in certain
commits and so we did all this by
combing through data that includes some
natural language some structured data
and some semi structured data and what
we found was that we have we thought we
had a big problem because there was a
lot of data in a lot of formats
planet-wide the problem is much much
bigger we produce roughly two and a half
exabytes of data a year and this
estimate was made several years ago so
it's surely gone up best estimates are
that very little of that data is
actually ever analyzed and so this means
that there is the potential to gain
insights from a lot of data that has
never actually looked at and if you ask
a data scientist why we aren't looking
at more of the data they will probably
draw you a flow chart similar to the one
on the right where they say look from
the day that you give me a new data set
to the time when I can actually do some
analysis are all these steps in between
where I have to write some code or some
expressions for parsing the data and
I've got to make
sure I do that correctly and I've got to
do some semantic annotation and maybe
some other things and rosy pattern
language was designed to address those
first few steps okay so we did what
everybody did when we were faced with
unstructured and semi-structured data we
reached for regular expressions and you
will know that these are tools that have
been around for a long time the concept
of regular languages goes back a little
bit further but as a practical tool for
technologists to use it became popular
in the 70s and particularly with UNIX
and particularly on the command line and
this is an this is an interesting point
of origin because the usefulness on the
command line and while editing I think
led directly to how concise regular
expressions are which is great if you
need to be concise if you don't need to
be concise it means that the syntax is
fairly cryptic now fast-forward to 2017
here are 20 or 25 of the most common
regular expression syntaxes they are
mostly incompatible with each other
sometimes in obvious ways like some
supporting features that others don't
sometimes in very subtle ways that you
don't find out until the third or fourth
terabyte of data has gone through your
system and you're not getting out what
you think okay so how many people have
written regular expressions before yes
okay so you can all read that top one
and see yeah that matches that would
match a date yeah no problem but if you
were given the bottom one like would you
know that that matched an email address
you can probably figure it out faster
than I could I find this stuff amazing
that that people write regular
expressions that have hundreds if not
thousands of characters so the first
thing we observed was that if we're
going to have a domain-specific language
we have to be able to name these things
and there's several reasons for that one
of which is we can't keep going to Stack
Overflow to find regular
Russians okay and there there was a
great example that I sometimes show when
I have longer longer time for a talk of
a regular expression that is probably
twice as long as that email example and
it's for matching ipv6 addresses and
there's a lot of comments on Stack
Overflow
thanking the person for posting this and
then about 75 comments down someone
wrote there's a bug so one of the
reasons that we decided to we had to
name them was was not just reuse but so
that we could put them into libraries
and then when there's a bug we could
actually fix it in the library and
everyone would get the update and so the
libraries have namespaces like in this
case the net library are up at the top
the date library and each package
namespace then has a number of patterns
defined within it so I'm gonna kind of
speed through since you're a very
experienced regular expression audience
I'm going to kind of speed through these
three issues regular expressions are
notoriously hard to read and maintain Oh
has anybody ever gone and googled for a
regular expression help application yes
okay so this was another issue you go to
the web in order to debug something that
your that came up while you were writing
a Java program or a scale of program or
something okay
so what did we do with rosy and rosy
pattern language to make an improvement
on this we designed a syntax that looks
like a programming language so patterns
can be named you can have white space
and comments and I realize you can do
this in some regular expression
languages unfortunately not all of them
so when my team was trying to share sets
of expressions between different
programmers we had difficulty with that
the expressions in the rosy pattern
language also compose and this is
critical because regular expressions do
not compose easily you have to be really
careful so we wanted to be able to build
a set of small expressions and then
build up from
they're two more sophisticated libraries
okay this may be a surprise it was
certainly a surprise to us but regular
expression performance is highly
variable so this slide and the next are
the good the bad and the ugly which you
know if you speak Italian so regular
expression matching can be very
efficient right like we know from
college or the kind of reading we do for
fun if we're real super geeky like I am
that linear time matching right using
non-deterministic finite state automata
is possible linear timing the size of
the input but almost nobody implements
it that way
so what happens in practice is
exponential time backtracking is the
most commonly implemented algorithm and
it's used almost everywhere fortunately
if you're really good at writing your
regular expressions you won't end up in
a situation where your program suddenly
takes exponential time but it does
happen so here's an example of a 90
something character input and the input
is comma separated values it is one line
from a CSV file and yet if you're trying
to find out if the twenty-ninth field
was a gold-medal this takes sixty five
seconds to run in perl when it should
take fewer than that microseconds to run
so this kind of exponential backtracking
you know in a lot of small programming
domains you won't ever trigger it but in
a large domain where you have a lot of
patterns written by a lot of people and
there is a wide variety of data flowing
through at high velocity you will
eventually hit this and then your big
data pipeline is stalled so what did we
do our PL is based on parsing expression
grammars which I'll talk just very
briefly about but they are defined as
formally like regular expressions are
defined but they are strictly greedy and
possessive which means that backtracking
is really limited in the sense that you
have to control when you write your
pattern how much backtracking you're
willing to tolerate so it makes it
difficult to be accidentally
and efficient we also so at in the cloud
division of IBM we make a lot of use of
the ELQ stack elasticsearch log stash
and Cabana which has been great for us
for log processing and so we looked at
log stash and we said well log stash
uses grok which is a library on top of
regular expressions that lets you create
lists of regular expressions that you
can reuse so maybe we should use that
and we found log stash and grokken
particular ships with 120 common
patterns and and you can add your own so
why not stop there
well the caveats we found were there
aren't any real packages so there are
possible name collisions and some
implementations we saw of grok as you
load in different batches of patterns
from files in a directory
some of them will use the first instance
of a define name some will use the last
so there's a lot of irregularity there
and and of course there's still regular
expressions so they still look like this
and here's a diff so how many so how
many people can spot the error the
difference in quoted string from the top
to the bottom it's it's well actually
quoted string is easy one sorry it's I P
v6 so there's a difference between those
two entries and you know Lord knows
exactly where it is so so sticking with
regular expressions seemed like a bad
idea so we designed rosy pattern
language to read like code so that would
also then diff like code and be
maintainable and debuggable like code we
okay yeah okay
okay so I've said all this without
actually telling you what it looks like
so let's take a look here is a regular
sorry a rosy pattern language file that
defines JSON in I don't know about a
dozen lines and it can only do that by
making use of the definition of string
and number and word that were already
defined there is a recursive grammar in
there you'll see a grammar section
bounded by grammar and end and this is a
feature of parsing expression grammars
that is something that regular
expressions cannot do so one of the
things we observed while considering
different reg X libraries is that a lot
of them have extensions that let you do
things that are technically not regular
anymore regular expressions and one of
those things is matching recursively
defined structures so JSON HTML XML
things XML things like that and so
parsing expression grammars can do
everything regular expressions can do
plus recognizer recursive data
structures so what you'll see in this
file are the things you'd expect to see
in a source code file comments there are
references to modules you don't need to
import anything or declare a package and
unless you want to so it's easy to write
just a few lines of RPL that don't have
any boilerplate there are identifiers
like you can see true/false and null our
identifiers defined to match literal
strings true/false and null the literal
strings are in quotes which separates
them from what in reg X are known as
magic characters there's a lot less
magic here
so literals are in quotes and identifier
czar outside of quotes I'm not going to
talk you through the the grammar but
it's it's fairly trivial unit tests are
an important thing to note I haven't
seen a regular expression library yet
that lets you declare executable unit
tests
and for us that was really important
because when we are calling rosy pattern
matching functions from Python or from
Java or from go or from C we want to
know that at runtime in production those
patterns are going to work and not have
typos or bugs or other bugs and so at
Build time one of our build steps is to
run the unit tests which is something
that Rosie supports and I'll come back
to that okay so let's look at a few
features before we kind of look at some
more use cases so I posted a series of
tweets which were a little bit obnoxious
because they were called can your grep
do this luckily I didn't hear back from
any of the ex Bell Labs people but the
first thing is named patterns so here's
a curl command that pulls down what
Google's homepage looked like last night
and if we wanted to extract from that
from this this big mess of text all of
the URLs what would we do we'd probably
pipe it to grep and in this case if the
slide will event there we go in this
case we're going to pipe it to Rosie and
rosie has a grep command which more or
less emulates grab and I originally
implemented this just for command line
demonstrations and it turned out at IBM
to be one of the more frequently used
features was just the command line so if
I grep for net dot URL common what I get
out is is literally this output now I
could have said Rosie grep not URL but
net dot URL was written to match exactly
what the RFC says is a valid URL which
includes all words single characters you
know bizarre combinations of single
characters and numbers and dashes so we
wrote URL common to just take the common
kinds of URLs so this is a really useful
thing
you'll notice in the commanded vocation
there is a - oh subs - oaken trolls what
kind of output do you want and in this
case it's the sub matches which is kind
of a technical thing that's not
important here here was another can your
grep do this at the top I pull out lines
46 - 49 of the system log file in my
machine and then I pipe that second
command is take that same set of lines
pipe it into rosy with a match command
and here the pattern of matching is
called all dot things all is a package
that just has a collection of
collections of things and all dot things
is a disjunction of maybe ninety or a
hundred different kinds of things that
we might recognize it's not especially
fast this particular pattern but when
combined with syntax highlighting which
which is built-in you can get output
that shows for instance path names in
green and network names of different
kinds in red timestamps in blue numbers
of other kinds are underlined and random
words are in yellow and you can of
course customize that mapping and when
you write your own patterns you can
assign them colors so that as you work
at the command line you can recognize
things easily in the output and this is
because one of the other things that
really killed me about regular
expressions my teammates were rather
blase about this but I didn't like the
fact that all of the tooling simply
output plain text in other words it gave
me as a human being very little to go on
in terms of recognizing whether or not
it worked or recognizing whether or not
I found the thing that I was looking for
so this kind of syntax highlighting
turned out to be useful it's also the
kind of demonstration that managers
understand which helps keep your project
funded showing things in color is it's
nice okay and they can show that to you
know VPS and
they say wow that's great color okay so
so this is the kind of output I was
getting I was generating with Rosie
before I did the color output because
Rosie is capable of parsing of using a
grammar and parsing input that way which
is something regular expressions can't
do you do get out a parse tree and a lot
of times you're not interested in the
nesting of the different components but
if you were you could see that num dot
denoted hex a denoted hex number in
Rosie just something starts with 0x and
a hex number does not have to start with
0x but every denoted hex number has a
hex number inside which is with the 0x
removed so you can see the substructure
and if you were then taking this data
and piping it into another program for
analysis that other program could then
extract just the pieces of the match
that it was interested in okay there is
a formal basis for rosy I mentioned
parsing expression grammars earlier so
the Chomsky hierarchy you know came
around in what 1960s roughly and we you
may remember that the strict definition
of regular expressions is that they
recognize all the regular languages well
parsing expression grammars came about
much later early 2000s and as someone
who is very fond of computer science
theory I am so happy that people are
still working in this area and producing
new and useful things so when I saw
parsing expression grammars I said this
is great this is a principled way to
extend regular expressions to not lose
any power but to also recognize
context-free languages and some context
sensitive languages there are a bunch of
really interesting papers by the way
there is an open question as to whether
or not all context-free languages are
recognized that's I can tell you more
about that and then you want to know if
you ever want to talk about it later ok
so I wanted to mention some syntactic
and semantic similarities so our
pío and regular expressions both have
repetition in RPL day repetition is
always greedy and possessive but we use
the same syntax as in regular
expressions because other than the fact
that it's a possessive flavor of
repetition the concept is the same
we have also character sets and again we
adopted the same syntax as regular
expressions because the concept is the
same we did do a little bit of
simplification we looked at the common
errors that people make while
constructing character sets and we
decided right away that you should be
able to write a character set that is a
list of characters to match or a range
of characters to match or a named
character set but you shouldn't be able
to just mix and mingle and drop them all
together into a single set of square
brackets because that makes it hard for
people to parse if it's hard for people
to parse then they don't understand what
your intention was and maintaining it is
difficult and then of course we have
operations like look ahead and look
behind and negation and these are
simplified syntax from regular
expressions okay there there is there
are many differences between RPL and X
and syntax one of them is very important
parsing expression grammars are defined
with a choice operator that uses a
forward slash specifically because we
want to visually distinguish it from the
vertical bar in regular expressions so
the vertical bar is unordered
alternation so you get choice a or
choice B and you don't know or care
which order those are going to be tested
and it's not possessive in red X so if
one fails you will go back and try the
other one and if one succeeds but then
later the match fails you'll go back and
try the other one in parsing expression
grammars the choice is ordered it always
tries P first and then Q this is a place
where a compiler like the Rosi compiler
can be smart about ordering your choices
or giving you hints about choices that
are not in a good order so that is a
part of ongoing work but it's a slightly
different
concept I think I know what's going on
I'll just avoid hitting the podium sorry
okay
we do ship a standard library with Rosie
which used to contain everything on this
slide pre 1.0 when I released 1.0 I took
the stuff in green source code D
structuring and syslog type patterns
moved them over to a community
repository mainly because those are
things that will probably change in and
the collections will grow over time it's
unlikely for instance that some of the
other ones like the definition of ipv4
and ipv6 are not going to change and so
we can write those wants and simply
maintain them when bugs are found but
there's a variety of commonly used
patterns there okay I asked you about
debugging earlier because if you if you
search reg X help on google it gives you
roughly eight and a half million options
for pages you might visit so clearly
debugging regular expressions is an
issue we wanted to have better tooling
around debugging for rosy then we were
forced to use when we were using reg x
so here is a command at the at the top
of the screen that says echo something
that looks like a time into rosy and try
to match RFC 3339 time format which is a
very common time format and it doesn't
match so you get back no output just a
prompt and so you may wonder why didn't
it match and you may ask what is behind
the curtain behind the curtain is the
output when you replace the match
command with trace so if you say trace
instead of match you get out an entire
hierarchical trace which looks and
functions very much like a stack trace
and you don't need to learn to read this
here just like with stack traces you
will with a little bit of experience
learn to look to see exactly what's
going on and it turns out that the
failure point is down there near at the
bottom but
the key value is that every step of the
attempted match is shown and at every
step you get to see what is the matcher
looking at in the input and what sub
pattern are we trying to match at this
very point okay I have to speed up a
little bit okay there is a read of a
print loop I spent 25 30 years maybe
hacking scheme and Lisp and so I am used
to working at a repple and I think it's
a great way to develop so I wrote one
for Rosie inside the read eval print
loop you can type in Rosie pattern
language statements like import and then
you have a number of commands that are
outside of the language that are
commands telling the interpreter to do
something and so here is dot list so you
can dot list the contents of the package
that you just imported and there is dot
match so you can say I want to try
matching the D structure package dot try
all is the name of a pattern which tries
a number of D structuring operations and
here's some input that has a bunch of
numbers there semicolon separated they
happen to be in parentheses the try all
method looks for sequences of things
with common separators in between and
ignores and strips off the parentheses
brackets braces whatever and so what you
see is there are some snip marks here
where I left out extraneous input for
the slide but it pulls out the data one
point two three four five six and seven
and the pattern definition did not know
that the input was going to look like
that it just tried a number of things so
we're using this in a data science
package called Pixy dust from IBM okay I
already mentioned executable tests so
you can write your test cases which are
great ways of documenting what your
expressions are supposed to do and you
can run them and you can run them
hello okay okay it's not showing you the
output from running them sorry
trust me you can run them and then when
some of them fail you get details as to
why they fail okay so I want to mention
a few non CLI use cases because all the
examples I was showing you were at the
command line and then we'll finish up
the first non CLI use cases the one I
started with so I built rosy at IBM
because we had this big data pipeline we
have a cloud the cloud has a bunch of
DevOps tooling the DevOps tooling has a
plug-in sort of architecture and there
are integrations for around 200
different tools when our customers are
using our cloud and these tools we can
if the customer wants this we can
analyze commits and commit messages and
issues and responses and test outputs
and builds and deployments and things
like this we can even look at log files
from the running application so all the
way from dev along to ops and we can try
to produce insights on this data and so
what we did architectural II was
basically the pattern you see here all
of the raw data comes in gets run
through rosy to look for that pieces of
the input that are of interest to our
machine learning algorithm so it is the
first pass and feature extraction and
then it goes into storage where we do a
number of things on the data another
application that is quite interesting to
me personally is parsing source code and
if any of you saw a Max's talk on tree
sitter earlier today there's some good
overlap between what his system does and
what Rosie does even though they were
developed really differently for really
different purposes they're both good
ways of parsing source code in multiple
languages and in order to kind of
demonstrate the breadth I asked a group
of students at NC State in North
Carolina to write our PL patterns
to extract as many features as possible
from ten commonly used languages
including Bosch because a surprising
number of service outages are due to
errors in scripts big surprise in any
case this is a little bit
work-in-progress they're still finishing
out function bodies and class bodies but
they can pull out things like literal
strings comments imports exception where
exceptions are thrown a number of
different calls to logging so you can
imagine that without having to have a
parser for a particular language you
could do a lot by not so when you want
to parse source code and you don't have
a parser for the language it's still
possible to pull out just the pieces of
the source code that you're interested
in and if you can do this in a
principled way you will get out things
like actual statements and not
statements that are commented out right
unless that's what you're looking for in
which case you can do that as well and
then last secure engineering principle
so the did it again okay for people at
home watching the video I'm sorry oh is
that what it is thank you okay so the
okay now do something different the open
web application security project has
been putting out reports for what more
than 10 years yeah since 2003 15 years
now and every single report says
injection attacks are the most common
form of attacks against web applications
so what do they recommend what does
everybody recommend whitelist all the
input what does that mean you have to
parse every piece of input that your
application sees so what would you do
you would use regular expressions
because that's what everybody does but
that's what I'm trying to change there
should be a better way something more
principled perhaps something where
there's a library of shareable patterns
and
and we can maintain that library over
time as we learn about new attacks okay
I'm gonna finish up with how Rosie is
actually used not at the command line so
if you're programming for instance in
Python you do the same things that you
would do using a regular expression
library you get an an engine or a match
or you instantiate that some packages
just instantiate one and so they do it
implicitly when you load the package but
Rosie lets you have as many pattern
matching engines as you want which is
great if you're using threads of course
if you're using threads you wouldn't be
programming in Python so if it's it's
better used in go okay so you you get an
engine you compile some RPL and
compilation could be some string that
you assemble on the fly like in this
example or compilation could be done on
a single symbol and that symbol would be
something from one of the libraries and
then you do the matching there are some
weird Python things around strings
unicode strings versus strings versus
byte arrays the Rosie library right now
is not very pythonic which I understand
to mean embraces the idiosyncrasies and
hazards in the Python language we're
working on making it more pythonic if
anybody wants to help that'd be great so
today we support C and Python and go in
the past before 1.0 I supported node in
Ruby and Java and Lua and was aiming at
closure because that's my I'm so
thankful that there is a place for a
lisp programmer to go in 2018 okay so
I'm gonna update those libraries at some
point or or get some students or some
volunteers to help me because I I get
requests for these languages all the
time I should mention performance
performance is really good it's hard to
find comparable packages that do similar
kinds of work we compared to grok
because we use a lot at IBM and Rosie is
roughly five times faster on the same
problem extracting the same artifacts
from the same data I will note one thing
on our tests grok whether it was roaming
in Ruby or J Ruby dumped core when it
found a utf-8 decoding error this is not
great behavior in production it doesn't
completely stop it just drops that line
it never parses that line goes on to the
next one this shouldn't happen right
this bad thing so so anyway we're we're
happy with five times faster and we've
done literally no optimizations oh and
rosy is running single threaded here
unlike Jake rock which after the JVM
startup time apologies to all the JVM
language users enclosure after the JVM
startup time it works very well okay but
not as good as rosy so here I'm gonna
wrap up this is attributed as African
proverb but nobody can trace it back to
any actual place it's a wonderful saying
but I just call it proverb so here is
our roadmap which looks kind of empty
let me fill it in
ok so I'll tell you about one or two of
these bottom-right ahead of time
compilation right now when you fire up
rosy it takes you know some hundreds of
microseconds maybe or a few milliseconds
to compile all the patterns you're going
to need we could eliminate that startup
time by compiling them ahead of time and
saving them to disk top right
extensibility we have the ability to
write macros in rosy which are great
because just like in programming
languages they let you take syntactic
structures that you want to repeat with
some substitution and write them as a
macro so there's less repetition having
user written macros is difficult because
right now you have to program in Lua and
you have to know enough about the
internals of
so we're working on a macro
implementation language that is more
accessible and there are lots of other
interesting things going on so I will
finish up here with a call to join us if
you want to try out Rosie just do get
clone of our git lab repo and type make
and then you will have a local directory
bin which has been Rosie now that you
can try things out if you are interested
in contributing patterns or writing
tools that help people write and debug
their RPL that's great
we're always interested in new features
including features that help with
performance features that help with
writing succinct patterns instead of
longer ones so there's a lot of work
going on in those areas so now I'm going
to switch over to slide oh and take a
couple questions thank you
[Applause]
okay the one at the top oh yeah how does
Rosie interface to other programming
languages
Rosie's implemented as a C library
shared object and so you can load it
dynamically into things like Python and
Ruby and JavaScript or if it's also it
also compiles as a static library which
is great for languages like go given a
Rosie pattern does Rosie have a command
to generate reg X with identical
semantics wow this is really interesting
no but we're actually working on the
inverse problem so that will probably
give us some insight into this
particular problem I've got a student
who wrote a reg x2 RPL converter so so
that's a great start unfortunately if
it's limited right now because it only
looks at the proper strict definition of
what a regular expression is so if
you're using perl compatible regular
expressions and you want to put in you
know backslash s for white space or
backslash k for whatever that does it
won't recognize those but we would like
to take this and make it possible for
you to take reg X that you already use
and simply import them and use them as
our PL I never thought about going the
other way but if you're interested in
elaborating on why please let me know
okay we'll do one more
given a rosy pattern can you dynamically
generate a string for which it will
match we don't have that built-in but I
think this is a great use of formal
languages so once you have a rosy
grammar right it could be not a
recursive grammar it could be just a
straight linear thing a set of
definitions you could use this as a
generative grammar and you could use
this as the input to a fuzz tester which
would generate strings that match the
grammar so that you could then feed
those into a program or a system in
application that perhaps uses Rosie as
its parser
and so you know it will accept those
strings and you can now then test to see
the behavior of your application once
you know you're passing the input and so
yes I'm very interested in that that
topic and last one support logical rules
as part of the match we don't have plans
in that area yet but it's clearly an
interesting topic I'm a little bit wary
of stepping outside of the formalism
that we're using now of parsing
expression grammars only because the
history of regular expression expansion
tells us that
that when you add things in an ad hoc
way you can sometimes get really bizarre
results and and I do want to avoid that
but the idea is really interesting so
thank you again
[Applause]